right now we're prepping for a huge
battle but it's not the one you think
it's over who was right about the
pandemic if the outcome turns out to be
less devastating than predicted the
opinion verse will fall once again into
a prison of two ideas either the outcome
was less calamitous thanks to our
hygiene in distancing efforts or the
outcomes were less devastating because
the threat was oversold if you don't
believe me doctors still argue over how
they subdued the SARS outbreak from 18
years ago some credit public health
practices others say SARS just wasn't as
destructive as they thought the answer
to this is probably a mix of both but
that shouldn't matter now because we're
still in the thick of it and it's better
to be wrong in your over estimation than
in your under estimation because that
meant good news and maybe the over
concern helped create the better news
that allows you to be mocked for the
over concern
do you follow I barely do still if we
aren't given a light at the end of this
tunnel the public is going to make a
light of their own true we are patient
and unified but we need to eat and more
important we need to work we need a plan
perhaps created by a new bipartisan task
force Dana's idea to get people back to
work in phases quarantine the old get
the young and immune back to work
antibody tests and masks galore and of
course some social distancing remains
which means no mass gatherings there
goes my fan club but at some point the
younger and the healthy need to get to
work and they just might whether the
government says so or not civil
disobedience might not come in the shape
of a sit-in but in the form of a thermos
of hot coffee and a tool belt
so I Jesse I'm do I want people to get
back to work for selfish reasons because
of my hair every day I look more and
more like Paulie walnuts
I swear I'm turning into him look at
that it's been happening right before my
eyes
mr. president I would open the salons up
first yes I'm going to start
to get you a cut I'm gonna start icing
people and barring them out in the was
that place in Jersey I don't know
that pine berry I don't think we should
stereotype those types of people Greg
[Laughter]
this country Greg yes the top CEOs of
this country already say they want to
get this thing opened up but they're
afraid to say it publicly right because
the US media will chop their heads off
and they'll say that your mr. burns from
The Simpsons right you're a scoundrel
who only cares about dollars instead of
death right so we're gonna open it up
and we're gonna keep the social
distancing and you open it up by four
factors age region and job everybody
under 45 gets to go back to work
obviously you open up small retailers
first then you got to get the salons
open quickly for Greg and then maybe you
move to restaurants and social
gatherings like concerts way later right
this is way later this is at the very
end why the one way to the restaurant
restaurant maybe you don't listen you
got to open up restaurants sued yes
maybe you don't do it right away but
maybe that's phase two yeah and when you
open them up how about you don't go full
capacity you have maybe a table in
between each table like a movie theater
maybe three seats in between each
section because you got to get this
thing unplugged and then obviously New
York comes in later than Alaska we all
know that but Greg I think everything's
changed this relationship we have with
the government they've injected cash
directly into our bank accounts that's
going to be very difficult to turn off
right and then you have the president
who's basically ordering companies
produce this produce this now and this
is how much we want of it that's another
tempting thing for future presidents to
do and I don't know it's four trillion
from the Federal Reserve no one has any
idea what's gonna happen there so I
think it's all uncharted territory Katie
with the other one of the other
mitigating factors is the drug
treatments which were not factored into
the modeling of this outbreak
right because we weren't we didn't have
enough patience to try the drugs on
right and the doctors to try the drugs
on but now we know that there are some
drugs that the doctors are prescribing
that are working to keep people out of
intensive care and that are actually
mitigating the symptoms and allowing
them to go home earlier so that is good
and as the doctors have been saying in
these briefings the data is only is good
and the model is what you put in it and
that's what you get out of it so as we
continue to move forward if we get more
of these treatments we can not have as
many issues with the hospitals but in
terms of the economy you know I talked
to a couple of non-political people
about this who are really angry and they
believe that the shutdown is going to be
much worse than the virus itself and
that's the feeling that a lot of people
have when it comes to your point about
people wanting to get back to work and
maybe some civil disobedience I think
that you're absolutely correct about
that but on the issue of not
overreacting there's been some you know
criticism of whether we're doing too
much and and and you know if there's not
as many deaths as maybe they're there we
thought that there would be based on the
data well did we overreact but you can't
quantify something that didn't happen so
it's very difficult to figure out
whether that was a good decision or not
and people would say when it comes to
people's lives you always want to err on
the side of safety and that's what the
administration has done here ya want
I predict since you and I debate over
everything that for the next year you
and I are going to debate over whether
it was the the health practices or
whether we overstated the the threat
should we start now well yeah we can go
for it but I just think I think that you
know the idea is that if you overstate
it at least people who catches people's
attention they say oh my god this is
serious you know there's a threat to my
life to my family and then hopefully the
health practices kick in I do feel for
Jesse because I think lots of times
people on the writer say oh you know we
don't like government government's not
good well right now government is
playing an important role in each and
every one of our lives and I think we
have to understand which is a community
and we stand together as Americans I
will say this in response to the
monologue Greg I think that it would be
a mistake for us to
get out too early you know despite what
we might hear from mr. burns or Ebenezer
Scrooge about get back to work I think
if there's a second wave if people go
back and then they say oh my god this
thing is not over now we're experiencing
another wave there'll be a leap in terms
of people who feel but they were misled
and therefore there won't be the trust
and that will again crater the economy
one more time and that's slowed down the
necessary economic recovery because one
last point don't forget people under 40
get this disease not so much children
but a large percentage of people in the
hospital right now are under the age of
40 so it's not as if they're impervious
just because they're young you know Dana
I have I come into work and I see a lot
of people outside and I'm wondering why
does social distancing have to be
strictly an inside thing when there is
all this when there are people that can
socially distance using common sense and
be outside on a 65 degree day in the
springtime it makes sense to me to let
people out but and I think Americans do
have that kind of common sense and the
only thing I'll say about this is
imagine being in Britain right now where
believe it or not people are actually
calling the police on their neighbors
because their neighbors maybe went out
more than one time a day to exercise oh
man
honestly yeah everybody use a little
common sense if you're out there
exercising by yourself who cares yeah